voilà donc pour ce documentaire
passionnant didier cros la récupération
de points un passage obligé pour nous
automobilistes qui avons besoin de notre
permis pour nous déplacer pour
travailler chaque année près de 12
millions de points sont perdus en france
depuis son instauration en 1992 une
manière à l'époque d'améliorer la
sécurité routière alors près de dix
mille personnes mourraient d' accidents
de la route
aujourd'hui près de 3300 personnes se
tue encore sur les routes de france
comment améliorer encore ses chiffres
plus de prévention plus de répression
faut-il baisser la vitesse faut-il
brider les véhicules faut-il des permis
probatoire nous allons en débattre avec
mes invités et j'accueille d'abord
sandrine gaymard bonjour vous êtes
professeur des universités en
psychologie sociale à l'université
d'angers membre du laboratoire de
psychologie et spécialiste de sécurité
routière
oui merci d'être parmi nous ensuite
j'accueille emmanuel bach déléguée
interministérielle à la sécurité
routière
bonjour bonjour merci d'être avec nous
claude beaud vous êtes accidentologue
mon métier que je découvre bonjour enfin
pierre chasserait vous êtes délégué
général de l'association 40 millions
d'automobilistes bienvenue à vous je
voudrais d'abord qu'on a une petite
réflexion sur le documentaire que nous
venons de voir
sandrine gaymard qu'est ce que vous en
avez pensé est-ce que c'est assez
révélateur de ce qu'on peut voir dans
ces stages de récupération de points
oui j'ai trouvé que c'était tout à fait
révélateur vous est d'ailleurs j'ai
absolument pas été surprise des
réactions des participants à ce à ce
stage de récupération de points
la route à fait révélateur révélateur
est très intéressant à débattre drouet
effectivement et emmanuel barbe c'est
assez inquiétant finalement aussi ses
réactions un petit peu de déni de
responsabilité non ce qui serait
inquiétant c'est que ces gens ne fassent
pas ce stage de sensibilisation avec sa
réaction
donc je pensais plutôt positif au
contraire par ailleurs le film est légal
exemplaire qu'on a là est assez
représentatif 80% d'hommes en moyenne et
une sur représentation des 36 65 ans
c'est quand même une tranche d'âge sont
pas des très jeunes c
pourtant à noter en effet c'est très
intéressant et ça corrobore tout ce que
l'on sait ce stage de deux jours
c'est inquiétant pierre chasse rêve on
est vraiment des mauvais élèves sur la
route on peut pas on peut pas
stigmatiser les 40 millions
d'automobilistes français à quelques
automobilistes sur qui on va pointer une
caméra et qui ont peut-être des
difficultés enregistrées quelques
messages au bout d'un moment la route
c'est le plus grand réseau social de
france on est 40 millions dessus c'est
encore plus que facebook et sur ce grand
réseau social on va tous roulés il faut
se respecter et pour certains
récalcitrants
il va falloir entendre encore des
messages c'est en cela que le stage de
sensibilisation à la sécurité routière à
une véritable vertu
parce que si on ne faisait rien ces
messages qu'on leur donne peut-être
qu'ils enregistreront pas tout peut-être
qu'ils vont retenir une chose
deux choses mais au moins ça c'est fait
et puis vous savez au bout d'un moment à
force de faire un stage de stage trois
stages quatre stages je peux vous
assurer qu'à un moment donné ça va comme
vous commencez à vous coûter enchère
elle peut être que vous allez rentrer un
peu plus dans le rang oui mais ce qu'on
voit bien dans ce documentaire c'est y
en a certains qui ont même intégré dans
dans leur budget le fait de faire un
stage par an pour récupérer quelques
points parce que vous avez diverses
problématiques sur la route ou parce que
tous les automobilistes ne se valent pas
entre guillemets un automobiliste qui
fait quatre cinq mille kilomètres par an
et qui perdrait son père me faudra
qu'ils m'expliquent comment il s'y prend
en revanche pour des automobilistes qui
roulent énormément sur des routes qu'ils
ne connaissent pas chez un ami qui
commercial sur la région grand ouest
figurez-vous que sa part de rouen jusqu
à biarritz ça fait quand même beaucoup
beaucoup de route qu'il ne connaît pas
et il a une accumulation de pertes de
petits points qui le conduisent un
moment donné à ces stages et là c'est
plus la même problématique
certes la règle est là pour être
respecté par tous et par le plus grand
nombre mais on n'est pas tous les mêmes
on n'a pas tous le même usage de
l'automobile claude go sur cette
question de on n'est pas tous pareils on
n'a pas le même usage de l'automobile
est ce que ça veut dire qu'il faudrait
aussi à l'image de ces stages faire des
stages au cas par cas
c'est à dire prendre les individus selon
ce qu'ils sont ce serait impossible
techniquement mais je pense un revenant
sur ce que vous avez des hauts débits
passage obligé c'est pas un passage
obligé chez 20000 km par an j'ai perdu
un point depuis 1992 donc on ne peut pas
dire qu'on ne peut pas respecter la
règle et ce qui est intéressant c'est
justement de voir dans ces groupes dans
ce groupe il ya tous les intermédiaires
entre la social profond limite
pathologique mentalement jusqu'à les
gens qui ont des attitudes différentes
et ce sont ceux-là qui à mon avis
humainement été les plus intéressants et
disait à la fin que peut-être
effectivement il faudrait changer donc
ça pose le problème est sale pose au
niveau politique de savoir si la
dégradation du permis à points qui s'est
fait dans cet établissement il ya
exactement cinquante otages au pouvoir
l'amendement qui a permis finalement
avec des modifications d'avoir un stage
tous les ans pour moi c'est pas normal
d'avoir un budget de récupération de
points ça veut dire qu'on n'a pas qu'on
n'a pas accepté l'idée qu'il faudrait
conduire différemment et respecter les
règles je connais moi des chauffeurs qui
fournit mais vraiment trente mille
quarante mille kilomètres par an et qui
ont tous leurs points donc c'est un
problème humain de comportement c'est
pas quelque chose d'inévitable de perdre
des points on est fan gaymard vous qui
avez l'habitude de d'étudier ce type de
comportement on est différent face à la
route c'est une question de personnalité
c'est lié à quoi c'est beaucoup plus
complexe que ça parce que en fait vous
avez des facteurs qui sont certes des
facteurs on va dire individuel sur le
plan psychologique qui sont des facteurs
de personnalité mais il ya aussi des
facteurs qui sont des facteurs qu'on
appelle grupo c'est-à-dire collectif
donc c'est beaucoup plus complexe que ça
et alors qu'est ce qu'on apprend qu est
ce qu on entend par des complexes
enfin ça veut dire que parce qu'on est
ensemble sur la route il ya des éléments
qui vont jouer sur nous un individu sur
l'interaction c'est quoi l'idée alors
deux exemples
on peut être influencé par le
comportement des autres conducteurs
voilà donc l'interaction humaine c'est
quelque chose qui est je veux dire
nécessaire donc on est en contact avec
autrui ont réagi par rapport à autrui
on s'adapte par rapport à autrui il ya
des gens qui ont plus ou moins une
faculté d'adaptation par rapport à
autrui 16 avril il ya des individus qui
réagissent de façon plus ou moins
habiles par rapport à autrui en fonction
de ce qu'ils ressentent justement donc
c'est assez complexe parce que là dedans
il y a des ressentis il ya des émotions
et puis autre facteur qui va être un
facteur plus on va dire deux groupes
par exemple la problématique des des
travailleurs c'est à dire des gens qui
se déplacent pour travailler avec leurs
véhicules
1 on sait que ce sont des populations à
risque il y à des facteurs derrière qui
sont des facteurs plus on va dire
organisationnelle au niveau des temps de
travail etc qui vont devoir se greffer
aussi sur ça ça veut dire qu'en fait
leur voiture devenant un petit peu leur
bureau mobile ça va changer aussi leur
appréhension de la route
bien sûr il ya d'autres contraintes des
contraintes supplémentaires qui se
rajoute à ça donc en fait c'est qui est
évoqué tout à l'heure au niveau des
kilométrages c'est une chose mais comme
cela a été montré la politique de
sécurité au sein des entreprises a aussi
une influence sur les individus alors
justement là-dessus je voudrais qu'on
réécoute la seule femme de ce stage qui
avait une vision quelque peu
particulière de ses voyages en voiture
ma voiture oui c'est ma deuxième maison
quelque part une reste deux points
je viens y vraiment pour les points
parce que c'est catastrophique si j'ai
pu de voiture je peux plus travailler je
peux même plus me déplacer pratiquement
la notion de plaisir et de liberté en
conduisant
je lai un peu comme les hommes c'est
marrant cette cette identification
sûrement parce que je vis je travaille
avec la voiture
je vis depuis toujours dans un milieu
d'hommes donc j'ai aussi un comportement
atypique pierre chasserait c'est quand
même fou de se dire j'ai je vis dans un
milieu d'hommes je fonctionne comme un
homme au volant de la voiture
c'est ça que ça représente finalement il
ya une symbolique derrière derrière cet
engin c'est quelque chose qu'il ya la
liberté c'est quelque chose qui renvoie
en fait à un plaisir est-ce que déjà
faut pas casser ça pour réussir à
imaginer en fait une manière de rouler
ensemble qu'ils soient moins un mois axé
sur sur l'accident à terme je suis pas
d'accord on peut continuer à avoir du
plaisir on peut continuer à voir de la
liberté le tout c'est au bout d'un
moment on a des règles elles sont fixées
il faut les respecter un maximum je sais
que des automobilistes peuvent être nous
écoutez là à se dire
moi j'ai été flashé une fois as quand
même oui une fois d'accord on n'est pas
touché par la problématique du stage la
problématique du stage quand on la
regarde à la loupe on voit quoi on voit
des automobilistes qui perdent quelques
petits points par ci par là et il y à
une infraction lourde qui déclenche le
stage ça peut être de l'alcoolémie très
souvent ça peut être une ceinture un feu
rouge glisser un stop
bref et c'est là où à mon avis on est
arrivé au bout d'un système sur le stage
de sensibilisation à la sécurité
routière
on donne un message qui est globalement
positif mais on répond pas à la réelle
problématique regarder je vous donne un
exemple vous prenez un automobiliste qui
est comme ça au volant il se prend d'une
fois avec son téléphone y perd trois
points c'est assez c'est la règle points
ces trois points il va les récupérer au
bout d'un moment quelqu'un qui a 12
points et qui se fait prendre une fois
il aura retenu quoi qu'on lui a pris de
l'argent on lui a enlevé trois points
mais ça il va les récupérer
point il ne fera pas de stage nous on
milite pour des stages en alternative à
la sanction
je m'explique c'est pas un
assouplissement c'est loin d'être un
assouplissement
on prend cette même personne qui s'est
fait prendre avec son téléphone tenu en
main et on va lui dire monsieur vous
allez faire une demi-journée ou une
journée ce sera à créer inventer de
stage on va vous expliquer les réelles
problématiques et dangerosité de lui
lisa sion du téléphone tenu en main va
se retrouver dans un groupe tout le
monde prie pour la même infraction
là on va faire quelque chose de
pédagogique parce que ce qui me gêne
dans le stage de sensibilisation
aujourd'hui c'est bien c'est positif il
faut continuer mais ce qui me gêne c'est
qu'il ya toute une frange de la
population à qui on aurait pu faire
passer un message globalement positive
de sécurité routière sur des infractions
qui leur est propre
donc alors que là en fait finalement ce
que vous êtes en train de dénoncer c'est
que il ya une forme de 2dt rhône et des
d'hétérogénéité en fait du public qui
fait que le message ne passe pas y
assister
je les ferries on est en train de
préparer nous aussi un film sur les
stages de sensibilisation à la sécurité
routière
je les ai vus j'ai vu ce qui se passe à
l'intérieur il y à une multitude
d'infractions et les formateurs sont de
bonne volonté ils veulent faire passer
mais on sait encore positivement il ya
un petit peu de difficulté par chasser
le messager malbar vous êtes d'accord
est ce qu'il faudrait pas une
alternative à la sanction
bon d'abord elle existe il existe il
exiger un certain nombre de contrôles où
on ne sanctionne pas les gens les
gendarmes les emmène dans des zones où
on leur fait en les sensibiliser aux
problématiques de la sécurité routière
par exemple les effets de la vitesse de
l'alcool et c'est rohff ça se fait très
régulièrement j'ai assisté récemment
dans l'ain et ses remarquables problème
c'est qu'on entre guillemets très peu de
personnes à la fois ça c'est une
difficulté par ailleurs sur les 326 1244
pour être précis stagiaires de 2014 y en
a 22 1903 qui sont dans un cadre
judiciaire
donc ils sont des gens qui ont été une
alternative à la sanction par le stage
donc ça existe le problème pour y être
d'accord avec cela mais
c'est d'abord de touché suffisamment de
personnes se posent des problèmes
organisationnels important et
deuxièmement je crois qu'aujourd'hui il
est difficile d'ignorer que c'est
interdit de conduire au volant donc dire
que de téléphoner au volant pendant
conduire au volant c'est mieux donc à
partir de là ça on est obligées compte
tenu des des masses en cause 40 millions
de personnes qui conduisent on est bien
obligé d'avoir des méthodes qui sont pas
les plus fines c'est certain mais je
crois que cette cette voie là est déjà
suivi qu'on puisse la développer encore
plus pourquoi pas c'est pas
nécessairement nos idées qu'est ce que
vous en pensez
est ce que on assure une bonne formule
ou pas je pense que aussi la formule
arrive au bout de ses possibilités parce
que pour plusieurs raisons d'abord celle
que vols indiqué il ya des gens qui ont
intégré le fait qu'il récupèrerait
quatre points tous les ans l on peut
aussi modifier la loi et dire tous les
six mois où on enlève pas de point et
les gens viennent simplement un peu mais
il faut tout de même voir que le pouvoir
de dissuasion de la sanction il a fait
sa soeur depuis longtemps et au niveau
de la route et on est actuellement dans
une phase où il y a une forme de mauvais
fonctionnement de mauvaise gestion des
pratiques qui fait que les gens ne sont
pas égaux devant la loi et à mon avis ça
il ne supporte pas il faut savoir que
parmi les gens qui ne devraient perdre
un point ou deux points ou 3 points
il y en a la moitié qui ne les perdent
pas c'est à dire que là le constat de
l'infraction du délit est fait et quand
on regarde le bilan des retraites points
les points ne seront pas retirés parce
que des dizaines de méthodes ont été
mises en oeuvre pour éviter cela j'en
donne une elle est bien connue
les chefs d'entreprise bas ils ont des
flottes de véhicules
s'ils ne sont pas capables de dire qui
conduisait le véhicule et bien on voit
que la majorité d'entre eux ne le font
pas alors qu'ils pourraient le faire les
sociétés qui à mon avis sans de bonne
société qui respecte les règles et la
vie en société
ça qui conduit normal le particulier
pardon mais le particulier le
particulier et au sens je suis flashé
pour 2,2 km heure je reçois quelques
quelques semaines après leur très bon
point donc
alors deux choses vous n'êtes pas fâché
pour deux kilomètres à l'heure puisqu'il
ya déjà cinq ans oui de retenue c'est
différent vialli en fait sept kilomètres
à l'heure où tu ne sais pas ça c'est que
vous vivez et les journalistes sont
partis des gens à risque dans une
atmosphère de précipitations est pressé
avoir des rendez vous qui vous rendre
plus vulnérable une évidence mais le
fait que vous dites dans les couples par
exemple c'est fréquent de dire je ne
suis pas qui conduisait sur flash a été
pris par l'arrière et on a installé à
l'homme la femme c'est vraiment le cas
mais bien sûr c'est qu'il faudra bien
sûr la stratégie du c'est pas moi qui
conduisais en plus on attend et puis on
des ondes énonce quelqu'un d'autre il
existe d'ailleurs je vais très franc
elle va exister mais pas pour très
longtemps j'ai l'impression que parce
qu'il ya des mesures qui vont arriver
bon moi ce qui me choque dans ce que
j'entends je suis plutôt d'accord avec
vous ça vous savez on est d'accord
finalement on est souvent d'accord pour
enfants très souvent en désaccord
profond vous voyez finalement
aujourd'hui pourtant une chose il ya une
chose qui me gêne un petit peu je quand
vous entends j'ai l'impression qu'ils
ont enlevé plus de points j'ai
l'impression qu'il faut empêcher les
gens de faire des stages de
sensibilisation pour récupérer les
points que vous appelez acheter les
points moi je regarde de manière assez
pragmatique et vous savez de temps à
autre on se dit on a retiré le permis à
quelqu'un tant pis pour lui
non pas tant pis pour lui réfléchissons
un peu peut-être tant pis pour nous
parce que qu'est ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui dans les chiffres on a une
augmentation des délits de fuite la
conduite sans assurance
la collecte conduite sans permis
pourquoi parce que ces gens là au bout
d'un moment quand ils n'ont plus de
permis
certains conduisent ces
pas tous certains conduisent quand même
j'ai regardé hier les chiffres de
l'accidentalité de la conduite sans
assurance
c'est sans équivoque ce qui conduit sans
etc et sans assurance sont une
population à risque
le facteur risque c'est x 2 x 4 en
termes de mortalité sur les routes
je pense qu'au bout d'un moment
heureusement qu'on a des stages de
sensibilisation à la sécurité routière
heureusement qu'on a ce système là parce
que sans ce système je crois qu'on le
père est peut-être beaucoup plus cher
alors justement on va un petit peu parlé
de caisse que qui sont les victimes en
fait de la route aujourd'hui on parle
des 18 24 ans est-ce que c'est
effectivement cette tranche d'âge qui
est la plus touchée par les accidents
mortels ou est-ce qu'on voit que ça
finit par toucher aussi une plus grosse
partie de la population et bayal
varrault assurément les jeunes par
rapport à ce qu'ils conduisent sont les
victimes privilégiées
si on peut appeler ça comme ça sans
sembler des victimes très importantes
sont sur-représentés dans la mortalité
au sein de cet âge il ya aussi les
motards veux qu'ils sont par rapport au
kilomètre qu'il parcourt extrêmement sûr
représentés on voit monter aujourd'hui
une catégorie de victimes de la route au
sens large
chez les personnes plus âgées qui sont
souvent des victimes aussi en tant que
piéton quand vous dites plus âgés ce à
partir de quel âge on prend des cadets
des catégories statistiques au delà de
65 ans et puis il faut distinguer au
delà de 75 ans maintenant en termes de
toutes ces statistiques sur la route
sont compensées par les grand nombre ce
qui fait que la tranche d'âge du milieu
est évidemment en nombre en valeur
absolue la la la plus élevée ici ce qui
me frappe dans ce dans ce film que on a
vu ces c'est tout de même de voir que
c'est beaucoup d'hommes et d'un certain
âge j'avais dit à l'instant et ça c'est
assez caractéristique autrement dit il à
la violence routière le problème du
mauvais comportement routier est quand
même un comportement très largement
d'hommes et c'est vrai que ça il faut le
il faut le souligner et c'est un aspect
qu'il est qu'il faut prendre en compte
dans l'évaluation des mesures qu'on à
prendre et puis je voulais revenir aussi
sur ce problème que soulevait le
professeur go sur les points il a tout à
fait raison de dire qu'il faut lutter
contre le fait de passer les points ne
pas s'acquitter de ce qu'on doit aider
les autres à le faire par exemple dans
la gestion familiale coupes dans les
couples
du point dans les entreprises il refile
les points moi je j'ai souvent dit que
les syndicats devraient s'emparer de
cette question pour empêcher les
entreprises de prendre à leur charge la
perte des points parce que à la fin du
fin qui est victime d'un excès de
vitesse ce sera soit celui qui fait
l'excès de vitesse soit celui qui sont
sur sa route mais c'est certainement pas
une bonne chose pour le salarié du monde
donc il faut assurément avancer sur ces
questions et faire en sorte que
l'égalité devant la loi soit respectée
gens aussi aux étrangers qui font sur
nos routes et qui domine alors c'est
normalement au niveau européen c'était
censé être
il ya une directive qui s'en occupent
qui permet des échanges avec un certain
nombre de pays c'est progressive parce
que tous ne sont pas dans le système ça
va venir mais pour l'instant c'est juste
une perte de points d'argent c'est une
amende mais c'est pas une perte de poids
donc il faut travailler sur cette voie
là pour que non pas comme disait caché
frères supprimer le nombre de points je
pense que il baissera tout seul si on
arrive à travailler sur l'égalité devant
les points et je rejoins totalement le
discours du professeur go / là dessus et
le gouvernement va s'y employer
alors quand on dit que les populations à
risques sont essentiellement des hommes
pourquoi les femmes sont responsables
plutôt cette responsabilité qui grandit
dans un processus de socialisation
oignons ou des familles explique aussi
que les femmes sont ce que l'on appelle
plus la nature la plus interne plutôt
alors plus interne moi qui suis plus
elle est bonne les écolières n'avait
bientôt elles sont plus matures qui a
une sainte ses capacités à entre paradis
alors de son environnement c'est à dire
qu'elles font plus de lien entre elles
mêmes et ce qui leur arrive que les
garçons alors l'âge c'est à dire qu logo
le dire à travers ça fait près 45 ans 4
50 ans que j'étudie les accidents quand
on regarde la différence entre les sexes
et entre jeunes et vieux
il faut bien voir que quand
l'accidentalité globale diminue ces
proportions là restent les mêmes
j'ai l'ombre qui diminue vous avez la
même proportion à peu près de jeu
qui mord que en 2000 il ya deux fois
moins de morts dont il ya deux fois
moins de jeunes qui meurent sur les
routes ça montrait bien qu'il y a des
caractéristiques qui sont liées au sexe
à l'âge
et puis il y a les différences
individuelles et là on voit par exemple
pour un fait qui est évident hommes
femmes
quand on regarde les pertes de points
pour des contrats gens sur alcon on est
dans une proportion hommes femmes qui
est encore très différente de ce qu'on
voit par exemple pour laisser aux
alcooliques du foie et l'alcoolisme sans
conduite parce que en gros on dit
l'alcoolisme féminin au monde c'est pas
vrai quand on regarde sur les
statistiques de mortalité depuis 50 ans
il ya quatre hommes pour une femme qui
meurt d'un problème d'alcool et si vous
regardez les points c'est 10 à 12 fois
plus d'hommes que de femmes
et là c'est un défaut du documentaire
qu'on a vu on ne voyait pas abordé le
problème de l'alcool mais je suis
d'accord là avec ce que dit zahia serait
que dans ce cas là il faudrait il
faudrait qu'il y ait des stages alcool
et téléphone au volant
par contre les élèves s'il est la
répétition des stages qui permettent de
regagner quatre fois à des gens qui vont
vite dans la vienne sur les jeunes sur
les toits mais il ya des différences de
comportement mais sur les femmes
il ya un point mais qui est fondamental
c'est que en ce qui concerne la prise de
risque en général les femmes prennent
beaucoup de risques
pourquoi est-ce qu'elles ont une
espérance de vie beaucoup plus longue
que chez les hommes qu'elle convient
mieux non c'est que dans tous les cas de
comportement elles savent se préoccuper
elles ont un signe ils vont voir un
médecin
là où un certain nombre d'hommes
resteront accrochés à leurs comptoirs
béarnais jean geiler grand chose et
quotidien pour voir leur médecin ce sera
30 sera trop tard quelles sont justement
on parlait de la vitesse on parlait de
l'alcool est ce que ce sont les deux
principaux critères d accident
aujourd'hui il faut les mettre sera une
échelle différente
la vitesse c'est constant il n'y a pas
de vitesse n'y a pas de mort donc sa
première fois les avances de l'ex mais
c'est pas pour autant une vitesse avec
une infraction on peut conduire à une
vitesse nord
et avoir un sanglier qui traverse on
peut aussi ne pas prendre la précaution
tout en respectant la limite de vitesse
de passer à un carrefour sans précaution
donc les morts vitesse sont très
différentes les unes des autres et comme
il n'ya pas l'enregistreur de vitesse
dans les véhicules ne connaît pas par
contre l'alcool il ya une mesure
obligatoire il ya un taux légal
d'alcoolémie 1970 il ya des contrôles
aléatoires il ya finalement tout un
système qui permet de savoir et on sait
que la proportion va être stable elle
est toujours d'un tiers des morts liés à
l'alcool ça veut dire que les facteurs
qui ont diminué le nombre de morts liés
à l'alcool n'ont pas influencé la
conduite sous influence de l'alcool et
ça c'est intéressant parce qu'en
sécurité routière c'est pas suffisant
d'identifier une cause
il faut être capable d'agir sur la cause
sur la cause alcool on n'a pas su être
efficaces qu'elles seront pourquoi on
n'a pas su être efficaces donc logo
manuel barbe pourquoi est-ce qu'on
n'arrive pas à agir sur le l'alcool je
suis pas certain qu'on a été si efficace
maintenant c'est vrai que ce facteur et
restent stables simplement parce que sur
la vitesse on peut mettre des radars
tous sur l'alcool on essaye de
multiplier les contrôles mais c'est pas
facile donc un des objectifs du
gouvernement ce sera bien d'essayer de
multiplier ces contrôles la relève par
exemple que la limite a été abaissé pour
les jeunes conducteurs cède 0,5 à 0,2 on
est parti d'une idée assez simple
consisté à dire un jeune conducteur par
construction il n'a pas beaucoup
d'expérience donc l'alcool fait scioli
un effet beaucoup plus fort et beaucoup
plus vite et surtout surtout un jeune
jeunes du mal à ne boire qu'un verre et
donc où il boit pas ou alors il va voir
beaucoup tant que c'était une mesure de
bon sens maintenant
l'alcool c'est sur une prise de
conscience à mon avis qui a quand même
progressé ces dernières années
aujourd'hui quelqu'un qui reprend le
volant est évident qu'il a un peu bu il
est mal vu est ce que ça va encore dans
la société jusqu'à lui prendre ses clés
ou à le faire dormir chez soi comme le
préconise la sécurité routière dans
certains milieux oui donc on a progressé
mais maintenant c'est vrai que là la
part en valeur par valeur
proportionnelle comme disait professeur
gones ne bouge pas c'est un aveu un
invariant qui est sur lequel il faut
lutter mais c'est difficile ses
largesses
vous savez faire des comparaisons avec
les pays étrangers ça a toujours une
limite ça c'est sûr parce que la france
n'est pas l'italie n'est pas
l'angleterre n'est pas l'allemagne c'est
une réalité
en revanche moi est quelque chose qui
m'inquiète et qui m'effraie quand je
regarde la proportion d'alcool
d'alcoolémie présente dans les accidents
mortels un tiers ça fait peur et je me
dis là est quelque chose d'inacceptable
je pense qu'il va falloir un choc
psychologique et un choc de comportement
en france peut-être même avec une mesure
mais pour enfin avoir une france qui
sera au même niveau que les pays
étrangers sur l'alcoolémie et la
mortalité alcoolémie qui peux me
regarder et à voir en toute honnêteté me
dire moi quand j'ai bu deux trois quatre
verres je conduis pareil que si j'avais
pas vu personne
il faut être honnête moi aussi ça
m'embête de temps en temps je suis
amateur de bons vins
moi ça m'embête de temps en temps d'être
à table et de me dire je vais conduire
derrière je veux pas voir
elle me plairait bien la bouteille je le
fais pas oui je ne fais pas je baigne
dans le milieu je le sais il faut pas ça
trouble notre comportement et je pense
qu'il va falloir très vite en france un
choc de comportement à leur alcoolémie
est ce que le choc de comportement c'est
les éthylotests démarrage oui ça peut
être l'éthylotest antidémarrage pour les
récidivistes mais pas pour tout le monde
quelqu'un qui boit pas au volant qui est
déjà
qui est déjà responsable au volant est
raisonnable on va pas lui infliger une
peine pour une frange de la population
qui respectent pas les règles une mère
de famille qui va chercher ses enfants à
l'école quand même pas la faire souffler
pour démarrer le véhicule parce que
c'est vous ce produit sion est oui
l'éthylotest antidémarrage est un très
bon exemple du fonctionnement notre
système et de la qualité du
fonctionnement de ce système on est
d'accord que on ne peut pas l'appliquer
à tout le monde on peut le faire pour
des conducteurs de cars scolaires mais
quelqu'un qui ne pourraient pas il ya
tout de même une contrainte qui est une
contrainte même si les quelques lignes
la seconde qui est pas acceptable
par contre il faut être capable
d'appliquer cette peine complémentaire
pour les gens qui ont une récidive de
conduite sous influence de l'alcool ça
paraît évident la loi elle a été floutée
à 4 ans elle est toujours pas mises en
oeuvre
non c'est pas qu'elle ait pas mis en
elle elle peut être mises en oeuvre mais
elle n'est pas mise en oeuvre pour des
raisons organisationnelles on n'a pas su
faire des contrats dans les grandes
entreprises entreprises qui fournissent
en gros tous les accessoires automobiles
y en a des centaines de bonnes car il
n'y aurait que 30 de dire à tous les
juges vous avez dans votre soeur la
possibilité de le faire et puis ensuite
former les juges les juges sont très mal
formés à l'accidentalité un mois j'ai
fait un peu de formation à l'école de
bordeaux c'est atterrant alors que c'est
un des domaines où il ya le plus de
travail pour les magistrats donc vous
voyez dernière chose en ce qui concerne
l'alcool
vous voyez le chief contravention délit
chaque année 6 environ 250 milles et on
a quelques dizaines de personnes avec
des idées aux tests anti démarrage ça
c'est la faire livrer d une pratique de
gestion
si l'administration fonctionner comme
des entreprises qui ont des contraintes
avec des obligations de résultats on
aurait un changement total de
l'accidentalité hallebardes
qu'est-ce qu'elle fait l'administration
ça a l'air simple comme ça sur le papier
alors tout à l'air toujours très simple
sur le papier ici lorsque la loi a été
votée nous avons rencontré des
difficultés énormes à la fois pas de
trouver des fabricants il y en a qu un
seul actuellement sur le marché et son
produit était très difficile a homologué
par rapport à l'état français donc tout
cela a pris du temps sans doute trop
mêlé démocratie il faut pas jeter leurs
règles aux orties immédiatement raison
vous avez tout à fait raison mais nous
avons aussi des règles et au nom de la
lutte contre l'insécurité routière il
faut pas non plus que on bafoue nos
règles ensuite il ya eu des carences
dans l'organisation liée au fait qu'il
ya aussi beaucoup d'autres urgences en
matière de criminalité qui fait que ce
dossier a peut-être pas avancé aussi
vite qu'il ne devrait mais bernard
cazeneuve s'en est emparé les choses
avancent petit à petit nous avons de
plus en plus d'installateurs qui sont en
capacité d'installer ce programme il ya
quand même ce système il ya quand même
chose qu'il faut que je souligné que qui
n'a pas été évoquée à l'instant c'est
que lorsque l'on prononce ces
condamnations souvent une grande
proportion des condamnés choisissent de
ne pas installer ces systèmes parce
qu'ils sont trop chers
alors la question est est ce que la
collectivité doit mettre doit financer
ces systèmes ça se discute pas ce que ça
coûte environ pour les particuliers 1500
euros voilà donc c'est des questions qui
sont un peu compliqué cela étant le la
dès est une très bonne mesure
l'éthylotest antidémarrage il faut très
certainement les temps parce que en
l'étendant vous fera baisser ses prix et
donc on incitera les gens à s'en occuper
et je crois que c'est une voie dans
laquelle résolument nous souhaitons
nous embarquer alors il y avait une
autre voie qui aurait pu être possible
mais alors il semblerait que ce soit
compliqué je voudrais qu'on réécoute
l'un des stagiaires que l'on a vue dans
le documentaire qui parlait de la
possibilité de brider les voitures moi
je veux savoir pourquoi on nous vend des
voitures ni dépasser 130 kilomètres
heure alors que nulle part alain groisne
dépassé cette semaine
est ce qu'on peut faire confiance
individuellement à chacun pour être
totalement raisonnable la seule façon de
le faire c'est de mettre entre les mains
des gens des véhicules qui se conduisent
pas dit qui monte pas dans les tours et
puis qui sont qui se conduisent
raisonnablement comme on veut que les
gens conduisent pourquoi on vend des
voitures qui sont et qui sont pas
limitées à 130
la réponse est très simple c'est parce
qu'on les achète oui parce qu'il ya
désormais l'industrie automobile
personne n'aura le courage de limiter
brider les moteurs à 130 pour vous
alors je voyais l'extrême dont je me
suis occupé allant jusqu'à un recours
devant le conseil d'état pour obtenir
qu'on délivre pas de certificat
d'immatriculation à des véhicules qui
vont trop vite puisqu'on à une
disposition du code de la route
disons que les véhicules doivent être
conçus pour assurer la sécurité dans ce
canton avait montré dans livre blanc de
sécurité routière 88 que les véhicules
les plus lourds les plus puissants tu es
blessé 16 fois plus que les véhicules
les plus raisonnables
pardon que c'est aussi grâce à la
sécurisation de ces véhicules qu'on
avait moins de morts sur les routes
c'est évident bah oui mais dites donc
les subversifs travailler avec les
constructeurs toute ma vie pour
améliorer les structures de véhicules
heureusement qu'ils ont contribué à la
division par dix sept de la mortalité au
kilomètre parcouru mais en ce qui
concerne la vitesse on connaît le sax et
l'allemagne l'allemagne vraiment à
gagner beaucoup d'argent et l'allemagne
elle dévient lourd rapide d'une très
bonne qualité et très grande que la
france avait demandé parce que la france
l'a demandé début des années 2000 2
qu'il y ait un débat européen pour
limiter la vitesse à la construction
parce qu'on limite les poids lours est
descendu à 3 tonnes 5 on limite les
scooters
je dis même les tondeuses à gazon ainsi
elle pouvait aller à 50 à l'heure il y
aurait beaucoup de jardiniers du
dimanche entouré autour des arbres donc
on est avec une situation où on accepte
danger inutile une forme d'hypocrisie
salon c'est l'europe qui est vrai comme
ça parce que la france n'a pas la
possible affirmé agir c'est une question
de business quoi exactement d'argent
vous savez j'aime bien de pragmatique
qu'est ce qui se passe avec les petits
scooters qui sont brûlés à 45 et 50 ont
les débride donc demain vous brillez une
voiture à 130 qu'est ce qui se passe on
les débris du système fiscal sera pas du
bruit des est confisqué mais oui confie
t il
écoutez monsieur go si vous me sortez
une étude de 1988 j'ai beaucoup de
respect pour l'année 1988
moi personnellement j'avais 9 ans mais
elle est actualisée mois les la suite
c'était humeur aujourd'hui quand je
regarde quand je regarde avec
pragmatisme
les chiffres de l'accidentalité il faut
arrêter de faire croire aux gens que
dans les accidents mortels sait que des
voitures puissantes et allemande c'est
pas vrai vous pouvez pas dire ça sinon
vous envoyer un message ça attendez vous
envoyer un message qui et quoi qu'ils
aient si vous avez une petite twingo
clio il faut une troisième marque une
citroën saxo et que vous revenez dans
cette voiture là vous n'avez aucune
chance de mourir je trouve que ce qui
est intéressant dans la réflexion de ce
monsieur d'abord c'est un syndrome qu'on
trouve dans la sécurité routière que la
paille et la poutre
c'est à dire qu'on rejette toujours la
responsabilité sur quelqu'un d'autre que
soi même sur son comportement parce que
de toute façon la limitation de vitesse
ne changera rien au fait que si vous
roulez à 130 en ville au lieu de 50
vous l'aurez problème donc ici vous avez
typiquement une personne et en plus à
l'est dans un stage donc elle a
peut-être un problème avec la vitesse
qui dit cela c'est typiquement une
personne qui ne fait pas face à ses
responsabilités et c'est surtout comme
ça qu'il faut le dire moi je veux dire
une autre chose je n'ai pas
d'options sur ce débat en particulier
mais d'abord c'est respectable l'intérêt
d'une auto d'une industrie automobile
qui marchent en temps en tant que tel
mais je crois surtout que nos problèmes
en sécurité routière viennent d'abord de
la responsabilisation des personnes si
un matin quelqu'un qui part au travail à
5 heures de sa tâche pas dans ça dans la
cour de sa ferme au fin fond de la boîte
je vais pas mettre un policier ni avoir
un système qui lui met automatiquement
une ceinture et qui qui le bloque donc
vous voyez bien que de toute façon les
résultats ne pourront être obtenue que
par une modification du comportement et
c'est à ça qu'on doit attendre alors
maintenant je pense que quand on roule
sur nos autoroutes on voit aussi que
beaucoup de gens roulent respectent la
vitesse et je crois que c'est un point
qui est important à souligner c'est que
nous devons lutter contre un certain
nombre de comportements déviants
ces stages montre des gens
particulièrement problématique sur la
vitesse il parle pas de l'alcool alors
problèmes qui n'ont pas voulu de filmer
ce qui reste problème mais c'est par la
responsabilisation qu'on pourra lutter
contre ces phénomènes est donc je crois
pas trop aux côté mécanique même si
peut-être qu'un jour c'est la voiture
autonome qui mettra tout le monde
d'accord
je voudrais justement pouvoir entendre
sandrine gaymard là dessus comment est
ce qu'on peut améliorer cette prise de
responsabilité cette espèce de prise de
conscience nécessaire pour moi c'est
quelque part travailler sur justement
cette perception du risque
vous voyez quand on dit par exemple que
le trajet domicile travail
bon c'est là où on voit beaucoup
d'accidents pourquoi parce que les
individus sont en situation un petit peu
automatique
donc ils font ils font moins attention
donc ça veut dire qu'à ce moment là ils
sont pas conscients ce problème là si
vous voulez on le retrouve à d'autres
niveaux
et pour accentuer cette conscience en
fait effectivement la question de la
responsabilisation
le participant il est totalement externe
par rapport à ce que je vous disais tout
à l'heure c'est quelqu'un qui est
totalement externe mais les études
scientifiques montrent bien que les
sujets qui sont évalués comme étant
plutôt externes sont plus accidentogènes
donc plutôt externe pour être clair
c'est à dire des gens heureux north la
responsabilit sur autrui sur autrui ou
sur l'environnement sont plus
accidentogènes donc à ce moment là on
peut mettre en place quelque chose au
niveau de la prévention un par exemple
des outils qu'on utilise sur par exemple
des outils qui vont amener à faire
prendre conscience de ce risque et à
développer
l'internât lité et ça on le fait ça ça
ça existe ça ça existe et fait quoi
comme a menti et bien en fait l'epsic
les psychologues travaillent sur st
s'ils voulaient la problématique au delà
du comportement on n'est pas des
machines
enfin ce sont les attitudes qui sont
derrière c'est bien les attitudes qui
sont en amont on veut dire et là si vous
voulez il arrive un moment où alors là
où travaillent à marca non pas
nécessairement pas nécessairement
puisque la question de la psychologie si
vous voulez un individu mâle individus
qui est dans un groupe
la question des délestages il y à la
question de la dynamique de groupe qui
peut être positives comme négatives
effectivement on ne peut pas faire un
travail individuel sur le plan pratique
mais à certains moments il faut faire un
travail individuel
quand on fait une évaluation d'un
conducteur ont fait un travail
individuel et puis le problème
de la situation du groupe c'est que ça
inhibe complètement la problématique de
la désirabilité sociale parce que govou
bien faire la différence entre ce qu'on
peut obtenir en agissant au niveau des
individus aussi bien la peur de la
sanction que l'éducation la formation et
ce qu'on peut obtenir par des systèmes
automatisés
parce que on a parlé de la vitesse j'ai
pas dit que les véhicules étaient en
gros les véhicules rapides où on voyait
les morts j'ai dit proportionnellement
quand on a un véhicule rapide il y a
plus de risques d'avoir un accident et
de déçus les autres que sur les
véhicules légers mais on a actuellement
la réponse est la réponse c'est le
système qu'on appelle le lavia c'est à
dire la limitation automatique de la
vitesse pas celle qui est autorisé le
réellement ce qui fait que vous êtes
dans une ville à 50 vous ne pouvez pas
dépasser 2 50
parce que il y a un positionnement par
satellites et là c'est là où les
contradictions mieux succès alors là on
va voir l'argument qu'ils nous
expliquent qu'ils vous et moi pourquoi
il est contre le navia alors que c'est
un système enfin qu'il se plie fonds
galli il ya plus de radars clergé serait
le paiement a dépassé la vitesse berg a
également encore une fois mouche sèche
très pragmatique je regarde les études
j'ai regardé quelque chose sur le simple
régulateur de vitesse et on m'a appris
que tout ce qui vient apporter une aide
de ce type là mais qui déresponsabilise
l'automobiliste un peu au volant peut
être accidentogène
il est - il ya une réalité monsieur que
vous avez raison sur un point vous avez
raison sur un point
moi un automobiliste qui roule à 90 en
ville mais je vous dire franchement mais
tant mieux qu'on le prenne un conte le
pic ça me gêne paris si ça me gêne pas
c'est pas un automobiliste coincé un
chauffard mais vous êtes pour le lavia
mais écoutez moi s'il vous plaît écoutez
moi je pense que la clé se situe pas
dans dans systématiquement dans
l'informatisation des systèmes ou en
transformant nos voitures en cockpit
la clé c'est le comportement c'est pas
un four c'est pas dangereux en soi parce
que vous n'avez pas dans l'idée on se
dis pas tiens je vais ouvrir le four jeu
le plaquer ma main dessus pendant trois
minutes
on sait que ça brûle on le fait pas
ce qu'il faut c'est modifier le
comportement et le rapport à
l'automobile
c'est à dire qu'est ce que je fait cet
engin quand j'entends l'automobile c'est
une arme mais pas pour tout le monde
vous avez toute une frange majoritaire
de la population qui n'est pas
dangereuse et qui fait son automobile
un instrument de plaisir de déplacement
de skieurs mais il ya plein de visages
de l'automobile mais qui n'ont pas un
comportement dangereux et ils ne sont
pas équipés de limiteurs automatique de
vitesse
regardez vous monsieur go vous n'avez
pas limiteur automatique de vitesse mais
j'attends d'en avoir
est-ce que vous avez aimé compteur
j'aurais pu la regarder mais au goût et
l'avait éliminée au journal août
comment vous serez moins vous serez mois
adam foote répète moi à l'entrée celui
qui a regardé les panneaux le compteur
il n'est pas à regarder la route nommé
laversanne et un limiteur de vitesse en
voiture mais le ligne j'attends à la
vienne l'a déjà nous adorions zendaya
rayonne n'y avait pas de limites arrêté
sur cette question moi j'aimerais bien
puisqu'on arrive bientôt au terme de
cette émission on sait que les routes
les plus accidentogènes sont celles à 90
à double sens où on se croise avec en
plus des platanes et ses drames il était
question à une époque qu'on baisse la
vitesse de 90 à 80 sur ces portions où
est-ce qu'on en est emmanuel bach est ce
que ce serait une bonne solution pas il
ya une expérimentation qui a été demandé
par
ministre de l'intérieur sur un nombre de
kilomètres égale à 80 1 qui est en cours
qui a commencé début juillet donc on
attend un peu les premiers résultats ce
que j'ai je vais pas les révéler tout
simplement sont contradictoires je pense
qu'ils sont juste pas significatif donc
ça n'a pas d'intérêt de le dire il est
clair que pour ma part je ne contesterai
jamais que si on arrive à faire baisser
la vitesse on fera baisser le nombre des
accidents c'est une donnée de base de
l'accidentologie
la vraie question qui se pose c'est de
savoir ici pour baisser la vitesse
faut-il être prescriptif élire faut
aller à 80 sur certaines routes à 110
sur l'autoroute ou faut-il faire
respecter les limitations actuelles
c'est ça la vraie question j'ai tendance
à penser
en attendant les résultats de cette
exploitation que faire respecter les
vitesses de façon drastique est une
méthode qui fera baisser aussi bien la
vitesse tout en restant acceptable alors
très rapidement puisqu'on arrive au
terme de cette émission ça serait ça
fait quarante minutes totalement
opposées limitation de vitesse est
cependant quand je regarde l'opinion
publique et que je me penche un petit
peu dessus on est tous d'accord pour
dire qu'il ya certainement des routes
qui méritent pas le 90 qui méritent même
pas peut-être 70 ans va être père vous
avez des routes qui méritent de rouler
moins vite
je me dis 90,80 bon mettre l'opinion
publique à feu et à sang pour une mesure
qui finalement n'est pas acceptée pas
comprises il faut surtout pas la
généraliser mais par contre au cas par
cas à regarder ce qui se passe sur les
routes françaises ça me paraîtrait une
bonne idée et les préfectures peuvent
déjà faire simple en 73 la vitesse sur
ce réseau a été mise à 90 le mois
suivant il avait trente pour cent tués
en moins quand en 2002 il ya une
nouvelle règle il apparaît la promesse
de radars automatiques l'afep tolérance
sur les vitesses le mois suivant il y
avait trente pour cent tués en moins
donc on dit ligne à mars sur le diminue
la vitesse secondaire on aura la fin
comment est ce qu'on fait plus de
prévention du coup est ce que c'est la
vitesse
ou est ce que c'est vraiment une réforme
plus globale de la manière dans ton rôle
et du rapport à l'autre
oui moi je pense qu'il faut inscrire la
problématique de la vitesse dans une
problématique plus environnementale
et 30 conscience du fait que la vitesse
a aussi